October is the busiest time of year for
pumpkins looking to get into print ads
TV movies and more it's also when high
as one of LA's leading pumpkin agents
receive hundreds of headshots from
pumpkins looking to get work this kid
has got it okay so where do you see
yourself in one week as I listen to Seth
I realized four things one he's gonna be
a big star too I'm very lucky I can hear
pumpkins talk it really comes in hands
of an angel three pumpkin voices for
some reason sound a lot like Luis Guzman
and for I know a perfect place to get
set some work hey Doug yeah hey how you
doing you piece of crap
yeah Eddie people see a pumpkin in an ad
or TV show and they think oh the prop
guy or scenic guy just plunked it down
it's not true there's an entire audition
process if you're a pumpkin Andi is the
best guy in town - God you threw all
that they love sat over at the Vampire
Diaries
you surprised even me I mean I knew he
was good but not vampire thyroids and
there's no job too small for Andy he's
just passionate about helping pumpkins
find their place you're gonna put my
client right in the front where
everybody getting off the hayride is
gonna see him little guy I met at Trader
Joe's wants to be a dancer will show me
your stuff go ahead I mean the fact is
your old George it's not me it's the
business I think George understood I
think he took it pretty well actually
[Music]
he's not just an agent you know
sometimes he has to be a bit of a fixer
and he's not afraid of that at all seven
on line one sounds like an emergency
oh hey Seth yeah what's up babe what oh
my god Seth what have you done
[Music]
oh no no it's that waitress from the
Italian place the cops are coming step
we go go
[Applause]
well things have all worked out George
is dead but I did get him into a pie in
the local diner Seth doesn't have any
cops sniffing around about the lady
pumpkin from the hotel room and Josh the
dancer he's doing okay too
[Music]
I'm Andy Richter pumpkin agent
except the pumpkin overdosed is that the
idea yeah I guess